yeah this was an incident on on sunday
afternoon about 10 miles from here out
in the suburbs of minneapolis
um what was the routine traffic stop of
dante wright that
and we've all seen the video um that
escalated
uh and in the in the course of a melee
as he tried to get back into his car
he was shot once by one of the police
officers there now that police officer
kim potter
48 years old 26 years on the force as
you say has been taken into custody in
the last hour
she will be charged with uh second
degree manslaughter that's it's also
known as involuntary manslaughter in
minnesota
carries a 10-year maximum 10-year prison
sentence in effect it alleges gross
negligence
uh by the officer there was a question
about whether she could have been
charged with third degree
murder which would have needed they
would have needed to show an intent to
harm in what she did
and her boss the police chief remember
said that he believed she'd gone for her
taser
pulled a handgun by mistake and then
fired
uh that fatal shot she's actually
offered her resignation uh yesterday
that's not been accepted yet by the
the chief of police the feeling is he
would want to fire her instead
uh but again last night we saw protests
outside of the police station
uh in that suburb of minneapolis uh
people angry and calling for these
charges we wait to see whether
there'll be any reaction in lessening
that uh that tension now we have those
word of those charges and those charges
will be filed later today